what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
ranking the demon Slayers from weakest
to strongest you guys voted via
Instagram stories at anime uproar for
every demon slayer rank rather than
every demon rank which I'll probably get
to next when this video hits 5,000 likes
so smash that like button make it blue
and share the video with a friend if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell or you'll
miss new Demon Slayer videos when they
come out as I explained in the all 9
pillars ranked for weakest to strongest
video link in the description I won't be
including pillars here you can check out
that previously mentioned video if you
want to see how I drank the pillars this
video will be dealing with the non
pillar demon Slayers who are stronger
than mu data in the butterfly estate
girls sorry to them but will be dealing
with the stronger demon Slayers who have
accomplished significant feats in
battles against demons of course there
will be manga spoilers in this video now
without further ado let's jump into it
first off we have Kenya the wind pillar
Sun amis little brother unlike the other
demon stairs he can't use a breath style
however his unique ability to eat demons
and use demon powers afterwards puts him
well above the average demon slayer in
power against Coco Chabot the upper moon
quickly cuts Kenya's arms off and then
cuts his whole body in half this doesn't
kill him though because of his imitation
demon powers just when Coco ship was
about to cut his head off
big bro when pillar comes to the rescue
although Kenya is clearly the weakest
person present he does end up finding a
way to be useful because of the nature
of Kenya's power the more powerful the
demon he eats the more powerful he will
become when he eats parts of kakushi bow
his healing power improves drastically
allowing the two halves of his body to
be quickly reconnected Kenya thinks that
he's frustratingly weak but he remembers
when tangental told him that the weakest
person has the greatest potential
because Kenya is weak the enemy is
paying more attention to the stronger
pillars meaning that Kenya can
potentially catch Koko SIBO off-guard
Kenya eats part of Koko she bows blade
further increasing his power he
manifests the demon slayer Mark and his
gun starts manifesting co-coach evil
looking eyes on it
Kenya can direct the bullets to go into
Koko she bows flesh the flesh bullets
act like a blood demon art dye grow into
tree branches that trap Goku she bow the
branches even prevent him from using his
techniques at one point because of that
and muy chinos red blade so I mean Gio
may have an opportunity to
kakuka she was had all of these efforts
eventually lead to kakushi Bo's downfall
but ganya tragically dies from his
injuries as does Moe Ichiro despite not
being able to use breathing Kenya proved
to be very useful
yes his strength was partially dependent
on having strong demons around to
consume and he needed three of the
strongest pillars to create an opening
for him so he can attack a cushy bow but
he helped turn the tide in an extremely
difficult high-stakes battle for this
reason he deserves to be placed here
well above the average demon slayer next
up we have eNOS Kay who uses breath of
the beast style a style he created
himself but that's not the only unique
thing about him escape he also uses two
jagged blades instead of one normal one
these two blades give him more
versatility in battle he's currently
fighting moves on along with the others
in the manga but his most important
fight before that was again supper moon
to DOMA the second strongest supper moon
DOMA was impressed by his flexibility
and he knows K even managed to rescue
Connell sword without DOMA noticing what
was going on that's how quick and tricky
in those K is his insane level of
flexibility which lets him dislocate all
of the joints in his arms and then reset
them lets him get a surprising hit on
DOMA when dolma thought he knows K was
out of range
however when DOMA gets serious eNOS K is
very much outmatched
which is to be expected DOMA is supposed
to be the second strongest upper moon
after all any knows K isn't even a
pillar he knows K is able to avoid
getting frozen by using his sharply
sensitive skin to sense the slightest
chill in the air
overall DOMA is impressed by him
thinking that he's never met a swordsman
like he knows K and that he'll remember
him he thinks this as he's about to
leave but then she no boos poison kicks
in
he knows K assists Cano in finishing off
DOMA by sending his blades flying at her
own blade together the forces enough to
chop off dolmas rotten head they win and
in the end a Toscano supporting in no
sway as they move on to the next fight
you know SK clearly demonstrated he was
strong and he even impressed a much
stronger upper moon however he hasn't
had a significant upgrade or new power
reveal like Cano and ZENIT's who had
more on those later so I can't put him
any higher for the time being I think
his time will come to shine eventually
and then we'll probably have to readjust
this list next we have Cano to UT the
breadth of flower user she was arguably
the star of the DOMA fight even though
she
any no ski did play vital roles as well
she started fighting before in those key
even arrived then when the poison kicks
in she uses her vermilion eye technique
which in my view puts her above what
we've seen from in those case so far he
knows he gets captured by dolmas giant
ice statue but Cano is able to avoid it
long enough to get her blade into dolmas
neck
she used the Move flower breathing final
form Vermillion eye to accomplish this
extremely impressive feat this final
form raises her dynamic vision to the
utmost and makes surrounding movements
look dull and slow giving her more time
to respond the pressure the move puts on
her eyes causes bleeding that stains
them red and the move could even lead to
permanent blindness so the move is opie
but it also can't be used for long and
can have long-term negative side effects
still though for that brief period of
time
kana was able to do what the nosce
wasn't able to do she was able to dodge
Domas attacks and make it to his neck
her arms started freezing but luckily in
those Kay was able to add the extra
force needed to get dolmas head off as
mentioned after all this she was the one
supporting in no ski after the battle
even though she had been fighting for
longer for these reasons with the opie
Vermillion I move in her repertoire I
had to put her ahead of me no escape for
the time being
next I have xeni to the breath of
thunder user he has a sharp sense of
hearing and he can enter an Opie avatar
like mode when he passes out which is
easily one of the most epic things in
the series I specifically put sunny to
this high up because of what we saw
during his fight against the new upper
moon six kagaku now it should be noted
that kagaku was a sort of quick
replacement for upper moon six and
didn't have time to actually get used to
his demon powers but still the fact that
sunny to beat an upper moon by himself
is hype AF and goes to show how strong
he's become the only other person to
beat an upper moon completely on his own
was the talented mr. Peller mu Ichiro
who beat up ur moon 5 after he
manifested his demon slayer mark kagaku
was talented to begin with and we can
only speculate about how much demon
powers helped to increase his already
impressive power and speed still though
it wasn't enough to beat an on demons ne
to Zen its who used an original 7th form
that takes the form of a lightning
dragon which is already epic but what
makes it even more
impressive is that the MU is too fast
for even Kai Goku an upper moon to see
arguably sein Htoo could have finished
him off with this move even sooner
but he didn't possibly because he needed
time to make his peace with the idea of
finishing off his senpai so he took more
damage than was necessary and currently
in the manga he is already well enough
to fight Mouzon for all these reasons I
had to put Zane to this high up on the
list his development from scared
weakling to beating an upper moon by
himself is arguably the most impressive
instance of development in the entire
series next we have tangent oka module
the breadth of water and more recently
the dance of the fire-god user ton zero
is the protagonist of the series and the
seeming successor of you're a cheese
breath of the Sun style which is the
original and strongest breath pretty
much dance at the fire God is the weight
on Jos ancestors passed on Yuri cheese
breath of the Sun over the years so
considering all this it is not
surprising that I put tons of this high
up but let's get into some specific
instances that illustrate his
exceptional level of power it is during
his fight against upper moon three Icaza
that we see Tundra achieve an insane
level of power that puts him at least
temporarily above even a pillar like you
a cossack killed in goku and give you
even with a demon ser mark couldn't do
anything against it because i even broke
his sword with a punch which must be one
of the biggest flexes ever during this
fight
tundra accesses the see-through world a
key a transparent world only the
strongest demon stairs including your
ichigo may upper moon Lanka cushy Bo and
mu Ichiro have gained access to this
world
it lets demon Slayers see through bodies
using their senses the enemy's breathing
and the flow of their blood becomes
transparent and the user also gets a
faster and clear grasp of the
contractions of their own muscles it
lets the seer predict moves way faster
and dodge them aside from that ability
which Tonto had used before he also
enters a new selfless state during the
fight against Akasa where he feels no
hatred anger or fighting spirit while
gil was helpless against Icaza
tantra in this state is able to cut off
Marcus's arm without him noticing
immediately occas a census how much
stronger he's become he says that every
fiber in his being is telling him to
kill ton zero right away in this state
time passes by slow for tundra so he can
dodge attacks that are supposed to be
inescapable for exam
potential dodge the same attack that hit
you a pillar 100 times then country
doesn't just catch aqus off guard
no he flexes on him he tells him that
he's going to cut off his head akasa
knows what's coming but he still can't
stop the attack
tanjo surpasses Icaza speed if a casa
was a normal upper moon he would have
died after tundra cut off his head but
he didn't die until he regained his
memories and decided that he didn't want
to fight anymore
if Alcazar decided to keep fighting
tundra and GU would have been done for
hundreds past his limit and he didn't
even have the strength to hold his sword
anymore
luckily Arkansas had a change of heart
he even thought that the fight was over
and that he suffered total defeat at the
moment that Tundra cut his head off so
the extremely strong upper moon three
Icaza accepted defeat at the hands of
Tangier oh that fact alone puts time
sure above many pillars in terms of
strength now yes the selfless state
didn't last for long and took a huge
toll on tangelos body so that he
couldn't maintain it for long but still
the fact remains that Tundra completely
overpowered one of the strongest upper
moons for this reason I had to put him
this high up on the list last but not
least we're going to be talking about
the strongest demons they're your de su
bikuni I could have also mentioned his
brother up from moon Lanka Kushi bowing
this list since he was a demon sir but
I'll save him for two every demon ring
from weakest to strongest video so make
sure to smash that like button because I
will get started on that one as soon as
we hit 5,000 likes on this video anyways
back to you DG the strongest Demon
Slayer and the strongest character in
the series URI Chi is a breath of the
Sun user the original and strongest
breath he was born with access to the
see-through world and arguably with
access to the selfless state that Tundra
used against Icaza
as a kid who had never picked up a sword
before he didn't just beat but
embarrassed a sword expert his sword was
red and after being cut by it Mullins
body temporarily stopped regenerating
when he fought moves on Muslim couldn't
lay a finger on him the demon king of
pop had to run for his life like a
coward
Mulan's body exploded into 1,800 pieces
of flesh and UHG cut more than 1,500
however the remaining pieces escaped
recombine into a lump the size of a
human head and moves on eventually
regenerated although he kept far away
from you at Ichi for the rest of his
life yuuichi had given him PTSD for
centuries afterwards when something even
reminded him of you
she moves on would be deeply affected by
it aside from making the main villain of
the series look like a helpless pathetic
coward your DG confronted his demon
brother Kakashi bow before he died
KooKoo Shiva was no match even though he
was over 80 years old at the time you
did she fought like he did when he was
in his prime although he couldn't bring
himself to kill his brother
he proved that he could cut his neck
before Kakashi Bo could even draw his
sword after that goodies she died of old
age he died standing up with an
undefeated record not even death could
bring him to his knees now if he isn't
one of the most epic and opie characters
ever I don't know who is and that is it
for today's video remember to smash that
like button if we can collectively get
5,000 likes it will unlock the every
demon rank from weakest to strongest
video thanks again for watching this one
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or else you will miss future videos
if you want to help decide what videos I
make in the future also on instagram at
anime uproar let me know who your
favorite demon seer is and who you think
will be the strongest by the end of the
series I'm kind of hoping it's gonna be
xeni too even though he's not the main
character a special thank you goes out
to our patrons over on patreon who help
us survive YouTube issues and who helped
make videos like this one possible
especially want to thank our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings out
just $30 beat Anatolia Kazansky alpha do
angel Cruz team Sparky 65 cricket XP
Rohan Kapoor Jessica Maloney Emperor
otaku and Timothy Edward Vargas and are
the one to your patrons the ones who
stand atop all clans Stephen and Radha a
low lawn attempt makoto-kun the world
Steelers the school bus and Tyson quarry
No thank you all so much if you enjoy
our work you can support more by going
over to patreon.com slash anime op floor
and becoming a patriot today for as low
as one dollar if you do so you'll get
your name featured in future videos
alongside these epic people right here
and you'll even get access to a private
patient only discord where we talk about
anime
life and of course dank memes so check
out patreon.com/crashcourse
and support more content that way if you
prefer whichever way you choose to
support us you will get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see you space cowboy
[Music]